-The president keeps insisting
the Russia investigation
has found nothing,
even after his ex-campaign
chairman lied to the FBI.
For more on this,
it's time for "A Closer Look."
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
Democrats might control
the House right now,
but Republicans
still control the Senate.
The GOP-controlled Russia
investigation in the Senate
led by North Carolina Senator
Richard Burr said this week
they didn't find any evidence
of Russian collusion,
despite not looking at most
of the actual evidence.
And Trump has been touting that
fact in rallies
and TV interviews all week.
-They've been investigating
this Russia hoax for two years.
They found no collusion
between Donald Trump and Russia.
What's happened to me should
never be allowed to happen
to another president,
with investigations on things
that never took place,
like Russia.
You know, the Russia collusion
delusion we call it.
Oh, wow, Trump found
two words that rhyme.
[ Laughter ]
If he gets kicked out of office,
at least he'll have
a second career in advertising.
-Beanz meanz Heinz.
[ Laughter ]
And Trump wasn't just whining
about the Russia investigation
to friendly crowds at rallies
and at Fox News.
He's also been screaming about
it all week on Twitter.
These are all different tweets
he posted in the last week.
-Highly respected senator
Richard Burr,
chairman of Senate Intelligence,
said today that after an almost
two-year investigation,
he saw no evidence
of Russia collusion.
Not only did Senator Burr's
committee find no collusion
by the Trump campaign
and Russia,
it's important because
they interviewed 200 witnesses
and 300,000 pages of documents.
-The mainstream media has
refused to cover the fact
that the head
of the very important
Senate Intelligence committee,
after two years
of intensive study
and access to intelligence
that only they could get
just stated they have found
no collusion
between Trump and Russia.
-Senator Richard Burr,
the chairman of the Senate
intelligence committee
just announced
that after two years,
more than 200 interviews,
and thousands of documents,
they have found no collusion
between Trump and Russia.
Is anybody really surprised
by this?
-The Senate Intelligence
committee, there is no evidence
of collusion between
the Trump campaign and Russia.
-My God, they doubled
the character limit on Twitter
and it still wasn't enough
for him.
At this rate, they're going to
have to start sending us
bound copies of Trump's tweets
in the mail.
[ Laughter ]
"Honey, I just saw a roach
in the kitchen.
Hand me that Trump tweet."
The thing about Trump screaming
on Twitter all the time
is that it's easy to just
start ignoring him.
Sure, two years ago
when you woke up
and saw that the president
of the United States
posted an all caps tweet
at 4:00 in the morning,
you were like,
"Start digging a bomb shelter."
Now we all react
to Trump's tweets
the same way we react to a
telemarketer call during dinner.
"Yeah, sorry, no, America
isn't home right now, bye."
[ Laughter ]
The Senate investigation that
Trump has been tweeting about
is a partisan Republican
investigation
that didn't even look
at most of the evidence.
By contrast, when Democrats
took over the house,
they announced their own
investigation of Trump,
and Trump freaked out.
-Today the president targeted
the committee's Democratic
chairman writing,
"So, now Congressman Adam Schiff
announces after having found
zero Russian collusion,
he's going to go look
at every aspect of my life
both financial and personal
even though there is no reason
to be doing so.
Never happened before.
Unlimited presidential
harassment."
The president went on to add,
"The Democrats and their
committees are going nuts.
The Republicans never did this
to President Obama.
There would be no time left
to run the government."
-No time left
to run the government?
You don't run the government
now.
You're -- you're basically
the security guard
in every heist movie.
"Murph, wake up!"
"Ugh, I was just resting
my eyes!"
Also, the reason
they didn't do this to Obama
is because he didn't have
any corruption scandals.
I know this is hard to believe,
but we used to have a president
who made it eight years
without anyone who
worked for him being indicted.
Meanwhile, you rack up
indictments
like you're trying to fill up
a punch card.
[ Laughter ]
Obama didn't have --
[ Cheers and applause ]
Obama didn't have real scandals,
so Republicans had to make up
fake ones.
In fact,
Republicans subjected Obama
to so many ridiculous
investigations,
one guy even freelanced
and started
his own investigation
of Obama's birth certificate --
The guy who's currently
complaining
about hoax investigations
literally sent investigators
to Hawaii
for a hoax investigation
into Obama's birthplace.
-I have people that actually
have been studying it
and they cannot believe
what they're finding.
-You have people now down there
searching in Hawaii?
-Absolutely, and they cannot
believe what they're finding.
-It sounds like the real story
is you sent investigators
to Hawaii
and they lied to you to get
more time in Hawaii.
[ Laughter ]
For a scam artist,
he is very easy to fool.
So Trump's been screaming all
week that he's been vindicated
and that all these
investigations are hoaxes.
Now, that was already untrue,
but Trump's lie got even harder
to believe Wednesday night
when we found out
his ex-campaign chairman
Paul Manafort had lied to
the Special Counsel's office.
-A federal judge ruling
that Paul Manafort,
President Trump's former
campaign chairman,
intentionally lied to the FBI.
He lied to
the Special Counsel's team,
and also to a grand jury
in the ongoing investigation.
-Judge Amy Berman Jackson says
there is sufficient evidence
to say that Manafort broke his
plea deal with Robert Mueller
by lying about three
of the five matters
the Special Counsel singled out
for cooperation.
-This guy actually thought
he could lie to Robert Mueller
and get away with it?
I'm sorry, but have you met
Robert Mueller?
I mean, look at him.
Mueller doesn't need a polygraph
to tell you if you're lying.
He can just hold your wrist
and monitor your heart rate
himself.
If you whisper a lie to
your girlfriend in California,
Mueller sits up in bed
in a cold sweat.
Also, this isn't even
the first time
Manafort has committed a crime
while he was being investigated
for committing other crimes.
In June, for example,
a judge jailed Manafort
after prosecutors claim he
attempted to tamper with
the testimony of two potential
witnesses in a criminal case.
That was after he had
already been indicted.
Every time he commits a crime
to make things better,
it makes it worse.
When Manafort goes to prison,
he's going to tunnel out of
his cell into a smaller cell.
[ Laughter ]
And this isn't just --
[ Applause ]
This isn't just some sort
of so-called process crime
that has nothing to do with
the core question
of Russian collusion.
Mueller's office said Manafort's
lies go to the heart
of what the Special Counsel's
office is investigating.
For example, Manafort lied about
the fact he shared
Trump campaign polling data
with a longtime associate of his
who the FBI thinks has ties
to Russian intelligence.
He shared polling data with
a guy
tied to Russian intelligence
while Russian intelligence was
helping Trump win the election.
That is the definition
of collusion.
If someone said,
"I don't understand collusion."
Can you give me an example?"
You could say that.
It's like if the cops
got up in court
and said the suspect handed
money to a drug dealer
while the drug dealer was giving
him cocaine, and we're all like,
"Oh, I wonder if the two
are related."
[ Laughter ]
And the arrangement they had
to share polling data
wasn't just some casual
get together.
The details of the meeting
themselves
were incredibly suspicious --
from where they met
to how they left the meeting.
-The "Washington Post" reports
court records show Manafort
met with a Russian political
operative,
a guy named Konstantin Kilimnik
at a midtown Manhattan cigar bar
near Trump tower.
-That meeting occurred
on August 2, 2016.
The meeting between Paul
Manafort and Kilimnik
happened in a private cigar room
called the Grand Havana Room.
They were joined in that meeting
by the deputy campaign manager
and Manafort associate
Rick Gates.
The meeting appears to have been
so clandestine that it,
"Ended with the three men
leaving through separate doors.
-They met at a private
cigar room in Manhattan
and left through
three separate doors.
There are only two explanations
here.
Either they were coordinating
illegal election interference
with a foreign adversary
and trying to hide it
or they were filming a sequel
to "Goodfellas" called
"Goodfellas 2: It Happens
at the White House Now."
[ Laughter ]
Now, the central question
at the heart
of the Russia investigation
still remains unresolved.
We don't have all the details.
But what we do know for a fact
is that everyone involved
keeps lying about it.
Michael Flynn lied about
his contacts with Russians.
Paul Manafort lied about
Michael Cohen
lied about the deal
to build a Trump tower
in Moscow.
Donald Trump Jr. lied about
his meetings with the Russians
and Jared Kushner
lied about his age.
[ Laughter ]
"Sir, you can't come
into the cigar room."
[ Voice cracking ]
"But I just turned 18."
[ Laughter ]
There's still
a lot we don't know
about the Russia investigation,
but one thing we do know
is that almost everyone who's
under investigation has lied.
Either they're lying to cover up
something really bad
or they're suffering
from a serious case of...
-Russia collusion delusion.
-This has been "A Closer Look."
[ Cheers and applause ]